yeah welcome to this video five-minute
game on icc time 10 seconds down because
i need to change some setting in the
recording okay we've got a Queens gambit
accepted here so let's see what specific
line we we get while I was talking about
this 10 second loss i accidentally plate
neither three young move move two so I'm
in this some kind of Queens gambit
accepted with Bishop g4 and it's a lot
of that line for black knight c6 said
this is not very not very common yeah
one doubs of course this I wonder if I
maybe can now damaged his pawn structure
maybe even now playing G 495 yeah maybe
I don't really know what some
established own theory on this
yep like an suddenly just consider out
of the zone I didn't really take into
account yeah I could go g4g 495 maybe I
can just play this this also threaten is
simply the bishop on reform oh my is
given me a real complete bishop am two
bishops against two nights mmhmm yeah
this whole thing looks a lot like like
the chi Goran defense of the Queens
gambit with black gown having these two
nights against two bishops Queenie five
yet the idea said before which looks
kind of normal it's answered by our
Knight takes e4 and he's some um yeah
he's on the hook on h1 and the f3 is of
course hanging I could go just Kinney to
covering f3 and threatening you fo again
but the king of course will be some
liability on on on YouTube oh I could
simply treat the bishop it's also
possible ooh come on rook g'wan I mean
it's no no doubt that why it should be a
should be a lot better here it's
probably a really big advantage but in
blitz it's always a bit tricky with the
King position and a longer time control
game I think I'm like it's in big troll
maybe it's not so clear cut but down
that's only prefer white yeah okay I can
just play Bishop e3 now and then i
discovered this is simply a piece this
was the idea of kimi to covering f3 and
collecting the rooks in case of um
discontinuation if I would play Bishop
if I would play now this is like right
right if I played Bishop d3 probably go
with them Queen edge form and now I
could play a form you know my let's
player for prevent his his move f5f form
it's not ideal admittedly because it
doesn't exactly help my bishop on only
three but do I need to UM yeah make sure
that he doesn't have fun such a big
counter play I'd like to get my queen to
the kingside maybe queen d1 e1 odd or D
1g1 something like this okay this is an
interesting tribe it's maybe a banking
on on a sacrifice see what I can I can
first give this check and then take you
five ok i am don't believe this so which
it should work really but them yeah
let's see just go here Quincy five got
Guruji one
my two bishops spit a bit much and those
pieces are all around the king so we
should be three and f 2 are both helping
in defend in defending and some really
am hard to believe that this should be
sufficient okay Queen somewhere roar
rookie one maybe rupee one covering if I
felt further consolidating someone Queen
to d4 am also a good idea going to be
for eyeing the h7 pawn I can also just
push the deep on this at least ties them
down to the defense of age seven yeah
rizzo and sal this is simply no play
unless I make a mall slip on rook g1 or
something and kind of self made yeah I
think this is some this is too much
giving me two bishops against two nights
with the big center and no counter play
whatsoever simply m two too many I'm
assets and why it's positioned with
black only having trouble this line with
Bishop g4 is quite interesting but I
think usually they play it with night
b27 here or a six or something like this
but i'm not i'm not sure yeah thanks for
watching and i'll post the more nuts
videos in one batch but I now separate
them into separate videos that like I
did it like I did in the beginning I
think this is preferable for for various
reasons or
thanks for watching